what's going on guys
Godzilla its top to the box-office he
tore apart San Francisco and he's
divided a lot of people in fact it has
torn apart the screen junkies team today
we're gonna decide is Godzilla great or
on the side of Godzilla is great we have
the director and editor of screen
junkies Dan Merle I know
thanks for being here Dan I have to be
here yes you do and we have the creator
of honest trailers one of the best
beards in the business Andy signor
hey Andy good to see ya sorry we're
gonna have to engage in furious debate
how you you look a little lonely over
there it's true you're the only person
we could find that didn't like Godzilla
I happen to have an ace in the hole you
guys welcome my secret weapon
[Music]
damn Nick Mundy in the house it seems a
little unfair
how can we compete against Mundy they
used to hate me because of you now they
like me now you dicks like me so again
you guys thought the movie was great we
thought it was
those point of views are gonna square
off in trivial movie fights fight so you
love the movie yes I thought it was a
great movie I think the people who are
hating on the movie are being unfair and
their gun justly comparing it to Pacific
Rim which is a completely different
movie this is the grim was a kids
playing with toys movie then I just got
distracted with it was fine Godzilla was
devoid of any fun boo No are you kidding
good what about the where Ken Watanabe I
can't pronounce his name Ken wanton Ken
Watanabe yeah Ken Watanabe was actually
like odd camber was like let him fight
he was bored out of his mind he wanted
them to fight yeah you know they cut it
right there and the full the full scene
was him saying let them fight finally
yeah Oh house absolutely right because
the actors are so bored in this it was
like I think we should we will concede
on the bad acting of Aaron no not your
special here's the thing I did not care
about dead-eyed
Aaron taylor-johnson what's a dive
Elizabeth listen or they're dead I big
intelligence the directors fault let's
talk about hurt Angela because this is I
will grant you that character was
underwritten and bland but he wasn't he
wasn't bad he was not Jamie Foxx and
Amazing Spider he wasn't Charlie Hunnam
he wasn't Charlie Hunnam in Pacific
Grove we needed to keep Cranston he
would have kept the emotion going give
you that one
I'll give you I wouldn't have minded
that's undying and guess what France
also you wasted Ken Watanabe
because I don't know this is eerie no
horse you have Ken not one Navi national
treasure
great speech giver to Japan
yes no and to us there was no great Ken
Watanabe speech oh but the fight was a
fantastic quote no that was again there
was a member of another Ken Watanabe
line from any other movie and I know he
had the and he was like he might have
been my favorite character in the movie
Ken Watanabe for me it was a tie into
those old Godzilla movies because
there's always one very brave
authoritative figure who remember yes
the Japanese guys that connected here's
the thing to what Nick was saying there
wasn't the Ken Watanabe we didn't get
sucked in and really care about him or
any of the characters after Cranston
died and that's who we lived in with for
the most of time in the movie The
Trailer made it look like Heisenberg
Godzilla you gotta admit that Godzilla
vs. Walter White that would be a
different movie you probably still
awesome though specially if you got like
an atomic raid up to Godzilla size that
would be guys let's get to the meat and
potatoes argument yeah not enough bang
for the buck
ok pardon me going here for a second if
I'm gonna watch a porno I don't want to
a lot of talking I'm gonna watch a
Godzilla I don't want to be all talking
I want more boning in my porno and I
want more Godzilla in my Godzilla here's
my response to that yeah if you're
watching a porno yes and you blow your
wad 30 minutes into it mm-hmm you've got
an hour of boring left because you're
done it's 30 minutes in and you're done
and guess what that if that's a Man of
Steel that's having your boss fight an
hour into the movie and you're sitting
there for an hour and it's just sound
and fury and noise and doesn't mean
anything because you've seen everything
there it was all about the foreplay in
this movie all I did there could have
been better for play I you had seen him
battle those monsters earlier the
build-up it was jaws it was all these
classic monster movies I have an honest
question for you guys yes do you guys
like the movie because like you think
it's a great movie or that you're just
surprised it wasn't the worst piece of
the world I didn't expect it it's a fair
pointer to me you go in a lot of these
big movies and you watch it and you're
distracted enough you don't really
notice you know care and then after
was over to me the perfect signal
spider-man to watch it I was distracted
it was fine and then as you said with
your like that was a shitty movie I
guess to me yes i sat there i enjoyed
Godzilla are there flaws with him of
course there's flaws but they didn't
settle settle in me and make me bitter
about the movie and sour about it and it
would have been a sweeter ride if
Cranston was there and there was a just
one more big yawn sorry you wanted a
generic summer blockbuster and I for one
like the movie because it was never said
that it was not that it was a classic
monster moon it was a classic Godzilla
movie with a big boss fight at the end
and I loved it for me how about a mini
boss fight no they cannot execute at all
I disagree I watched it I had a good
time I thought Cranston was great in the
beginning the boss fight at the end was
cool if I can go see a big summer movie
like this that entertains me and my
biggest complaint about it is that the
lead guy was kind of bland for me that's
a win I mean that's like it wasn't so
awful that it ruined the movie for me
right I have a bigger problem with that
type of thinking because everything is
just so bland and mediocre and like
rememberin summer movies used to be
great no we used to be younger yeah
that's the other thing way too critical
yeah look the way I look at a summer
movie is will I watch this at 2:00 in
the afternoon on a Tuesday on TNT that
is the weirdest criteria I've ever heard
in my life buddy man she was on the
other day
totally totally whoa I'm right I don't
know I think if Godzilla was on and
national treasure was on on USA at 2
o'clock I'm gonna put on national
treasure it doesn't hold up that
criteria of a great summer movie your
days are pretty free honey maybe I'll
agree with you that Godzilla's not a
summer movie but I'd argue it's a better
movie yes okay we'll stop it the movie
had its flaws what did you think of the
movie what did you think of this debate
who comes out on top leaving
or in the comments section below best
answer we're gonna send you a screen
junkies t-shirt thank you for watching
the show and thank you to our familiar
cast of characters here Dan Merle Andy
signor Nick Mundy I'm Hal rod Nick hit
me up on Twitter follow us all on
Twitter thanks for watching bye bye I'll
talk to you on Twitter gotta be
Wolverine yeah as you can heal so fast
and like all these weird aches and pains
I feel just like existing will go away
like this 76 years old